hey there and welcome to Westeros weekly
the show that answers your biggest
questions about every episode of Game of
Thrones I'm Erik Voss
I am the mold Queen that's right Maude
Garrett is here this week Philip stout
Maude we won't ring any bells to piss
you off when you hear bells yes happy to
have you and a reminder all of our Game
of Thrones coverage is available in our
Westeros weekly podcast feed get our
season 8 content audio form earlier than
the video versions and look for Westeros
weekly on iTunes or wherever you get
your podcasts also be sure to check out
our new MCU podcast inside Marvel for
all of our Avengers in spider-man
content now guys we were really excited
to announce there's going to be a big
event that we're planning this coming
weekend we are going to be in New York
City at the hotel Red Lion and Brooklyn
we will watch the finale and then we're
gonna do a live taping of new rock stars
live this is going to be a super fun
event where you can celebrate with us
and other Thrones fans or drown your
sorrows with Thrones themed cocktails
when the show breaks your heart either
way you're gonna be with people you love
watching something you love and we're
gonna be answering questions from the
audience we're gonna have a costume
contest with prizes a trivia contest
with prizes and you can hang out with
the new rock stars host me and Philip
which is it some kind of prize it's
depending on how much you like us
hopefully a lot oh and free food and
drinks which will help those unexpected
character deaths go down just a bit
easier New York was the top request in a
recent Twitter poll for a live taping
location and we're so excited to get to
meet some of our East Coast fans finally
for tickets and more information about
the event check out the ticket link in
the show description there's also a
discount code for the hotel Red Lion if
you're coming into the city and you want
to stay overnight we are just so excited
for this event and we hope to see some
of you there yeah that'll be that'll be
really fun
but we have a lot of great questions
that you submitted on Twitter with the
hashtag Westeros weekly and we're gonna
get all them but first as always we
always start with the big question
submitted with the hashtag on the
Westeros weekly on Twitter Oh
Oh Thank You Raven they're like trying
to go bran out and just gang hold on one
second go I could only work in super
potion maniac wants to know will aria
kill Daenerys alright this was actually
the most popular question they got by
far what a lot of people were
speculating about as Arya was left alone
wandering the city in the final shots of
this episode because that girl be cranky
if she's seen basically the damage and I
really like that the directors decided
to use her as a point of view to see the
catastrophic consequences of Danny's
actions so shoot should she and does she
have a new name on her list a new queen
every time she's like I'm going to kill
the Queen has it been Danny this holt
it'll be great if you just heard her
chanting Daenerys she's galloping in
Damaris but who knows what she was
hearing alright so I think yes that she
is going to substitute that this kill
list I think that even though you know
in the city she had this moment of I
don't know understanding that she is
vulnerable she is not you know immortal
she can be destroyed and with that I
think that she's realizing she needs to
use her skills to save a lot more people
here I also think that with Danny he or
she has superseded the evil that Cersei
is yeah and the whole time aya has been
like Circe's number one Cersei is the
the evil entity so to see Danny be even
more than that it's like you know what
we're all thinking it's like I thought
Cersei was the antagonist this entire
season no no yeah it was interesting
that Circe's reaction to seeing Daenerys
just mow down all those streets it's
almost like Oh like she's even realizing
I'm not as evil so I thought it was
there's a greater threat now this was
Jaime after they know that a huge battle
with the loose oh yeah the the black
water rush yeah
you haven't seen the Dragons I have like
they're really dangerous and she's like
doesn't matter I'm seriously he just
wouldn't good shot
yeah and then she's like I'm screwed
yeah you've got I use bond with Sansa
being so strong and the fact that
science is conspiring against Danny I
think the answer being the brains and I
are being the Brawn they're gonna again
do exactly what they did with
Littlefinger oh right
play executioner play the game and never
see ya little we're hearing about the
brown eyes green eyed blue eyed thing
with yeah prediction their Danny's got
green eyes would they have been fixating
a lot on what's on these greens and
Jessica's in the books like the targets
are suppose to have like purple or
lavender colored eyes but in the show
they haven't really gone as far with
that berry just keeps a Clarke's color
and one last point with aya we know that
she's got this sneaky little skill where
she can steal faces and wear them and
there's only the people of dead people
the faces of dead people that she can
take there's a lot of dead people now a
lot of people a lot of dead like still
potentially pristine faces that she
could feel off I mean we saw Daenerys or
it's Cersei and Jaime get destroyed
collapse and rebel but we didn't see I
got Bonnie rebel in a good condition to
be peeled off well let's make the case
against De Niro or Arya killing Daenerys
yeah it was really bad writing ah sorry
but if you look at one of the better
written scenes of this episode was Arya
and the Hound in that map courtyard the
Carmindy at San Diego Map Room that that
they I love that that's set by the way
and she said thank you to the Hound she
caught him Sandor which is interesting
because I don't think she's ever used
his first name it's supposed to be this
big moment to where she's been on this
arc toward vengeance and he said look at
me do you want to turn into me maybe
she's turned over more peaceful leaf and
she's gonna return to Gendry and live
happily ever after
she took that horse and she was writing
out of the city which I thought was like
an interesting shift for her she's she's
finally moved beyond her simple goal of
just destroying her way to her coolest
everyone on her kill list is gone I feel
like the moment that she said no to
Gendry
it meant that she was the most
consistent character throughout all
eight seasons she's never wanted that
lifestyle you know her needle wasn't the
meet them with the fancy little what are
they called cross stitch Oh next yeah I
mean there was I could see both
happening because you know characters
arcs have been subverted and changed
last minute in many different ways in
this final season so they really have
done a good job of making us feel oh
really any
thing can happen in both good and
empathic ways you could argue there was
that subtle visual clue mightier talked
about this of whom who might kill whom
this episode like there was that awkward
kiss between Daenerys and Jonna
Dragonstone and and it's interesting
that he was saying that this kind of
this actually did happen a few times
throughout the episode so when she's
trying to use last or intimacy to get
and gain his full support even though
he's like cringe granted as my aunt and
even though they probably had sexy is
like a few too many times for him to
finally care now look at where I hands
up
take me mm-hmm what she's basically that
yep that's a control which is like by
itself a totally fine way to kiss
someone but then it comes up again later
this episode when Jamie is holding
Cersei at the end the hand placement is
exactly the same and when the hound and
the mountain are fighting yeah he's like
three feet of there's no joking
happening yeah so it's like recurring
images of characters partners pairing
off choking each other and dying
together head up and with Jaime and
Cersei Devin with the Hound in the
mountain so does that foreshadow that it
might happen with this parent it's
interesting that it's like whoever's
sort of doing the holding is bringing
the other person down so it's like their
only reason why they're dead is because
that they are literally being suffocated
their entire life and existence through
them The Hound has been suffocated by
his feel for revenge
Jaime had his freedom had moved on you
know me Brandon fall in love with him
like that and then he had to go back
because he was being you know yeah II
kind of like restrained or obsessed with
by this woman right that almost it's
almost like addiction right and then
something I'll go more into in the
breakdown is you can look at Jamie's
decision to return to Cersei as like
addiction relapse you know he can't stay
away and the way that the Hound is kind
of on hell-bent on this mission to go
after his brother when he doesn't need
to but it's almost like this he's yeah
he's so dead that it's harder for him to
kill him like its to go for the head you
know at the end of the day so in the
same way that Jon like it doesn't really
make sense for him to be held back by
Daenerys but he's got this kind of like
he's words
his word is his weakness he gave his
word that he was going to bend the knee
and even though he doesn't support her
he's scared of her
he's he doesn't want to roll so that's
like he doesn't think he's gonna do a
better job than her but because he said
he would he's sticking by his word and I
think that that's what's keeping him
trapped with you interesting well let us
know what you think the biggest threat
to Daenerys will be whether it's arya or
something else might do her in but
before we move on to your other
questions about this episode we want to
take a moment to shout out to sponsors
who helped us bring Westeros weekly to
you every week cybercrime can happen to
anyone
crooks are out there trying to steal
your passwords and your credit card
details scammers make a lot of money
stealing data from people on public
Wi-Fi it's happened to me before so to
protect myself from cyber criminals I
use Express VPN it secures your internet
browsing by encrypting your data and
hiding your public IP address it has
easy to use apps that run in the
background of your computer or your
phone or your tablet I turn it on with
one click and safely surf on public
Wi-Fi and I feel completely secure have
that peace of mind for less than $7 a
month you can get the same expressvpn
protection that I have expressvpn is
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar and it comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee protect your online
activity today and find out how you can
get three months free at expressvpn comm
slash rock stars
that's exp ress VPN comm slash rock
stars for three months free with a
one-year package visit expressvpn comm
slash rock stars to learn more also our
other sponsor this week is away travel
they are a design company that makes the
world's coolest suitcases they're made
of polycarbonate material that's super
strong and super light perfect for when
you need to really get the hell out of
King's Landing in a hurry because there
is dragon fire raining down your home
and your new queen does not care about
whether you live or not this is there
everywhere bag I love this thing it's
great for small trips and even just in
my day to day life it's awesome some of
their other models even come with
built-in batteries to charge your
electronic accessories get your own cool
away luggage at away travel calm and use
the promo code rockstars 24 $20 off your
order
again that's away travel calm and use
the promo code rockstars 24 $20 huh
fantastic enter thank you so much for
making
you know it known because it is known
that this show exists because of
sponsors but I do want to take a moment
to talk about those that have fallen in
this episode their watch has ended we
had so many characters died the big one
of course being Lord Varys the spider
the master of whispers Danny basically
taught him last season that if he ever
portrayed her she would burn him alive
and Danny is a woman of her word and in
season seven Melisandre told him that he
would die in Westeros and that's exactly
what happened to in the season six
finale though he promised the Martel's
and Tyrells that Danny would deliver
fire and blood yeah accidentally
prophetic yes not Fire and Ice the only
ice that there was was not ice at all
just ash of dead bodies yeah we're gonna
talk about the part that he might still
play in the finale later now Twitter Q&A
though yes but what I'm really
disappointed with Varys is that he had
this great looming arc and story about
how he was captured and you know
utilised root and stem that's it you
know all from this sorcerer who wanted
to use his body parts to basically
sacrifice it there's a lot of light and
it heard through the flames something
something and conveyor I knew what it
was - so it's connecting the Lord of
Light yeah there might be some
connection here with the Lord of Light I
think last episode breakdown I kind of
speculated that Varys might have some
kind of role and I'm gonna dig into it
more for the breaker because I'm
interested in that question though is
that he didn't have to see him be right
right yeah because that was the
catastrophic like he was like she's
gonna she's unhinged Brandon yeah he and
he's like I hope I'm wrong but
unfortunately being dead then right yeah
also die this episode of character we
barely even got to know Captain Harry
Strickland of the golden company he was
the next major character to die the goin
company never breaks the contractor
really doesn't anything at all in battle
included bring elephants the one thing
that was a lot of people are saying that
is the same white horse that Arya finds
it might just be another white horse
that horse looked like it got pretty
messed up you know I did find myself
screaming at the television it's like
sure has no respect for animals and of
course there's you know women and
children being burned alive
people more upset on a direwolf dyes
than when a child Tyson but I don't know
if you look at that shot I looked at
over and over again a horse upside down
just looks confusing so I don't know if
its limbs are like horses are not meant
to be upside down and it looked yeah but
I don't think any animals were really
hurt the the VFX team did say that
Harry Strickland and his horse get like
messed up so I don't know but but this
guy is it was interesting and I'll go
into this more in this breakdown the I
think the whole reason this character
was introduced on the show is to have
like a point of view character for
selection ik to stage this part of the
battle from and he wanted someone who
could kind of parallel the way John was
shot in a battle the bastard so you
could kind of start to confuse the lines
of who are the good guys and who are the
bad guys in this battle you know he's
someone we should never root for he just
by the framing he kind of feel a bit of
antagonism toward the yeah yeah other
than hatred for the people come in but
agree yeah I don't care who that guy is
we've got your on Greyjoy the cockiest
bastard out there basically slept with
the Queen and he says that he slayed the
King Slayer kind of he's the kind of guy
he'll say anything to make himself feel
a bit better is even still the king I
mean you're Greyjoy reclaim the Iron
Islands away from this who's like yeah
I'm still the king I was once the king
always a king and I didn't see he Jaime
Lannister died but I got him I got a
good we've got a good one in before my
days wear you out
I like that he died with blood in his
mouth a yes
yeah well even though he kept talking
the halt I think he was like yelling it
as well that's annoying yeah um but he
didn't die on the water though yeah he
died on land he kind of rose back from
the water just for this one last fight
and then dies yeah unlike Theon beyond
died like landlocked in the middle of
nowhere it seems kind of odd that he was
how'd you feel about that moment with
Jaime and Euron really fulfilling at all
well if you if you've really invested in
these last couple seasons of urine and
Jamie being kind of rival figures for
Daenerys affections then yeah maybe it
felt kind of yes thank you sir seas
affections but as it stands right now it
didn't really feel as exciting as
cleganebowl I kept wanting them to cut
back to that battle because that
a longer-lasting tension as well like
basically the hounds entire existence is
built on his disdain for his brother but
in this instance it's like who knocked
up Cersei it's like an episode of what
is it who did the Maury Povich you
father and then they just started
fighting and then yeah right I didn't
feel I think anything with your on on
the show I haven't really felt
emotionally invested for just because
the character in the books is so more
dastardly and interesting and he's got
all these other backstory things and you
really get excited for him and on the
show he seems a bit one-dimensional so
it's been kind of hard to feel those
stakes but another death this episode is
a maester Qyburn basically dr.
Frankenstein killed by his own monster I
mean it's it was a little sad to see his
look of panic on his face as his head
was something against the wall you know
it was pretty hard to watch but it was
interesting he the mountain killed
khyber in a similar way how he killed
Elia Martell son during Robert's
rebellion yeah you know slammed him
against the wall and we saw him do that
a couple seasons ago - there was just
like a guy in the middle but I like the
fact that carbon really didn't think he
had yet ownership over his creation and
then the only thing that could supersede
that was obviously this being built
hatred that he had and so I kind of like
that cleganebowl took a next step and at
carbonia done yep yep and then who else
okay is speaking of the mountain finally
you've obviously the hand tried oh no he
tried to do the same move I don't know
about you else when I was screaming at
the television because those thumb
started creeping up his face going to
the eyeballs I can't go through this
again
but it was also so defeating to know
that every stab and I'm talking like
main arteries on the neck yeah a lot of
like killing blows I just was just doing
nothing
yes zombie right seen him before though
I'm pretty sure it was right yeah
there's definitely some Vader
connections there yeah yeah yeah
between the dark rhymer in the creepy
yeah but I do like the fact that you
know we've we've only seen him with the
helmet this entire time and of course
one of the first blows but we was
revealed that this is what he did look
like and then there was that sure trip
moment where his name mm-hmm I'm not I'm
not gonna say
yeah anyway yeah he's a big boy you know
it's good for them to show that too it
kind of brought him back to when we
first saw a half Thor bjornsen on the
show and he was like surely he was just
like beating the crap out of us boring
so it's kinda brought it back to it's
like yeah this is why this guy got cast
he's a good guy and then sadly his
brothers Sandor the Hound Clegane he it
was interesting his death he died
killing his brother and he died by fire
and he charged him plunged him into fire
so it's kind of confronting his fear of
fire in his moment and he had this nice
kind of fatherly moment with Arya and I
think we knew from that moment when she
said Sandor thank you and that goodbye
we knew he wasn't gonna be walking out
of their life death that it was it
anticlimactic well Jaime Lannister you
know he died he died - he told bran in
season 5 that he wanted to die in the
arms of the woman that he loved now
there was a call back when he was
imprisoned early in the episode his
shackled neck looked a lot like in
season 2 when he was captured by Catelyn
Stark and you know the battle would yeah
so it was like he's in this same
position yet again I mean he gets freed
not by Catelyn this time but by his own
brother Tyrion which is really cool
because he was able to return the favor
right yeah you freed me from from from
the King's Landing
- yeah escape yep so that was
interesting cuz we should talk about
also he died alongside Cersei Lannister
his sister happy Mother's Day
now the somebody were saying what about
the following car of all inquiry so you
guys keep correcting me that's not well
but like people on the show and George
Martin is called a fallen quark so easy
but there talk about that prophecy that
Cersei would die at the hands of her
younger brother that was not in the show
so what about the reference was only in
the books and like if the show wanted it
to be a big deal they would have
introduced it on the show but in a way
you could interpret this it did kind of
happen in the way she died with the
younger brothers hand around her throat
and it wouldn't happen it would have
happened that way if it wasn't for her
other younger brother Tyrion setting
that up she maybe probably would have
died another way but not in that
specific
tableau this death I think is angering a
lot of people because you know Jaime was
supposed to kind of be able to
recover from his addiction and see her
for what she is and instead of him
saying I to him a monster and I'm down
her level he was going to rise above it
all but yep there was no sense of like
you know Jamie Redemption there's no
sense of Cersei Redemption it was just
our trying to escape and couldn't how
did you feel I mean I think ever since
he left Brienne I've already kind of
suspected that his relapse has begun and
like having known people who suffer from
addiction and relapse that kind of
disappointment already kind of primed me
for this kind of disappointment and
that's just how some people are like
they're their inner biology they cannot
fight it and they end up going back down
that dark path and you can't really
expect them to satisfy what you want for
them and I think Brian's kind of moment
with a Brienne's moment with Jamie when
he knighted her and when when they
consummated those vows I think that was
as happy of an Indian as we're gonna get
for Jamie and then once he decides to go
back and leave her it's like oh this is
his true DNA is true character spirit as
the show is saying is to go back with a
sister even though he knows that will
doom him it's tragic but in a way if you
look at as a warning for addiction and
addictive people and toxic people in
your lives there's some kind of meaning
you can drive from it that way but I
understand why people are upset about it
yeah people after so much more like some
sort of symbolic or I or any kind of
accountability and repercussions for her
consecutive evil for so long I think
it'd be really cool if like during the
whole thing she got mad or you know her
hand was removed and so when Jamie's
there she's like there's only so much
like physical torture I can handle I
mean this is the one who has marched
through King's Landing naked as people
scream shaming through crap at her I
don't know what more you can do that's
really gonna rattle her yeah you know
she just needs to go all right but let's
move on to some other Twitter questions
Thank You Raven he's so vocal Lily
underscore meow asks what was on varus's
notes that's interesting so this is a
very first shot of the episode it's that
note the Varys is writing on Dragonstone
you can't see the entire note but we
were able to make out the following is
not the only Targaryen left Rhaegar and
Lyanna start
their son lives still hidden by Eddard
Stark his name dududu is the true heir
to the Iron Throne okay yeah so this is
the note that they're writing about John
and John's true claim to the Iron Throne
they're said that the Lords of Westeros
would rather have a man on the Iron
Throne then a woman and he's made it
clear that he thinks John would be a
better ruler as a better temperament but
when later when grey worm comes to
arrest Varys and take him on a survival
Tribal Council meeting he's right in
another note and he burns it and the
only to the back of it but you can kind
of make out the word Targaryen maybe he
was making another copy of the same note
from earlier hoping to get as many of
these out to the Lords of Westeros as
possible so he might Varys be sending
these notes too we know that there is a
new Martell printing Dawn Yara Greyjoy
is obviously captured the Iron Isles and
then of course there's the northern
houses and the Vale which is still
somehow thriving - sweet Robin is
building a snow forts up there to areas
where Sansa Stark actually has influence
so yeah by kind of getting that message
out there could easily turn everyone
against Daenerys who does not have an
actual right over the throne anymore and
that's good anymore right than it hurt
her claim is less legal she still has
like the kind of claim that Cersei had
when she seized the throne in terms of
just raw power and hopefully if fear you
know she said let it be fear then so if
that's her whole place is just basically
steal it that's kind of essentially what
Robert was doing was basically I guess
more powerful than any one else I'm
gonna steal and kill anyone who stands
in my way yep but yeah it's it was
interest you're bringing up before the
episode this is essentially what Ned
Stark was doing when you find out the
true lineage of Joffrey's just send the
word out to Stannis to everyone else
because it's the right thing to do yeah
but yeah that was the beginning of his
end there where it's like it's
technically treason even if you're
trying to do the right thing by get the
appropriate and suitable person on the
throne not suitable it's the actual heir
to the throne
but yeah whoever's trying to keep the
throne obviously sees that as a threaten
you they snuff that up right quick
absolutely and other people who could
ascend to let's not forget the iron bank
of Braavos they're the ones who loaned
Cersei the money to rent out the golden
company because they thought that she
could win the war Cersei has left the
game so maybe they'll side with Jon now
as someone who might have more of the
lords around the continent who are in
his favor and then Daenerys is influence
is now shrinking because she's just
burned all of her bridges yeah yeah but
a quick note about the little girl's
smile have you guys asked us about that
that little girl one of his little birds
she worked in the kitchen and reported
that Danny wasn't eating anything
so Varys said we'll try again at supper
it sounds like he was trying to poison
Daenerys he told her the greater the
risk the greater reward that's a pretty
big risk reward and we know Varys has
tried to poison Daenerys before yeah
using the wine a wine merchant got found
out yeah that's that actually was so
subtle that I missed it until we spoke
about it yeah yeah but I just I thought
that they were just honing in on the
fact that Danny was in some serious
mourning here not only mourning the fact
that she's lost her best friend but
mourning the fact that everyone around
her is betraying her yeah if it wasn't
for will try again at supper because I
did miss that line the first time I
listened to it at first I was just like
oh it's just a spy who's trying to get
into a room to kind of eavesdropping and
report back whatever she hears and she's
not even opening up her room to food
yeah let alone anything else but the
fact they wants to try a go at it the
next meal is interesting so that brings
up two things then doesn't it it brings
up does she know that that's what Varys
was doing and that's why she's not
eating and she's using you know mourning
as a way to do that and to maybe it has
worked a few times and she has been
cited to get getting a little bit
poisoned throughout it and has that been
affecting her mind kind of a slow drip
poisoning that's driving her mad yep yep
there's plenty of other reasons or at
least according to showrunners enough
reasons for Daenerys this sudden shift
into madness
but that could be another interesting
way to justify it oh okay here we go
ad - Brizzy p22 listen a will Danny kill
Tyrion for free and Jamie ah yeah tells
Tyrion exactly that this episode that
the next time he fails her will be his
last and last season she told beerus
that if you have a betrayed ho she'd
burn him alive she did woman ever word
um I think Tyrians run out of efforts
ffs ffs' but his loyalty has always been
his family from day one especially his
brother Jamie
he's been his only slash best friend
this whole time so of course Tyrion
freeze Jamie so that he and Cersei can
try to escape Kings Landing he sees so
sees the threat if he can safely remove
that he makes his siblings happy he
makes
everything go away problem solved right
yes but Jamie didn't have an impact on
the battle couldn't even get it through
that he couldn't even get through the
doors right yeah didn't get through to
go the wrong way yeah yeah so it's
unclear if Danny even knows that he was
freed like I don't think if they find
the body they're buried buried under a
lot what's going on
go get away with this but if he he has a
problem telling truth bombs lately even
when he shouldn't right he wanted yeah
yeah Tyrion is now pretty isolated at
least as isolated as Danny was in the
previous episode he's lost various his
old friend and fellow advisor and then
lost the only two Lannister's left in
the world he's the last Lannister
essentially he um he might be likely to
make some rash choices that's what you
do yeah you feel like no one else is on
your side and you've got nothing on no
one else you just lose your [ __ ] I could
imagine
Daenerys wanting to kill him she's been
pretty good about finding reasons to
view people as threats the way Varys is
like in season seven said like oh you
know people are ready for it she's like
oh oh but they're all singing my praises
and quiet oats and he's like oh I was
not ready to have this conversation
right now
so she even traced back the the leak to
Tyrion back and she's like hey so even
though there's other people were
betraying me more you also gossiped told
you knowing that you she's ready to do
it and I think if she is now the main
villain of the show as this episode
painted her to be absolutely she's he's
gonna be one of the many people on her
execution list I mean I'm talking about
which characters are consistent over the
time Tyrion has been known to be the
smartest his decisions are always
educated he knows and can read people
he's an observer you know he he gets it
mm-hmm
but all of seven and eight he hasn't
he's been completely out of touch he's
been making bad decision after bad
decision he hasn't been able to read the
play at all and now that it's come to
making a bet Varys betting on John him
betting on Danny he's realized he's put
all the efforts into the wrong person
but I feel like he's just he's out of
touch and I feel like all of these
decisions have helped make her you know
mad Queen interesting that you bring
that up
Tyrion strikes me as like a really
expert like poker player who is always
like dominating his friends like no
Texas Hold'em rounds and then like some
crazy person shows up and joins the
table and is such a badass and is just
going all-in on every move
move and he doesn't know how to play
opposite because there's like a whole
thing in poker if you play against
someone who doesn't normally play you
can't really read their tells
you don't and you just want that person
to leave because they aren't playing the
same game you are they're playing a more
aggressive game than you are and aren't
really following the rules of war yes
and Danny's been a completely
inconsistent character as well someone
who's you know had the people in the
first and forefront of everything she
wants to say if she wants to break the
wheel just want to be the wheel you know
she wants to change everything and it's
always been about putting people first
especially those that are lower down and
can't look after themselves which is why
above everything Varys and Danny should
have gotten along the best because they
really had the same intentions
throughout it and then slowly that just
started sort of like collapsing in on
itself where if you didn't do right by
her you don't get a second chance she
did not rule by mercy I still think
though that I mean my gripe is that they
did spend so long pinning her out to be
the person who does lead with mercy
seven minutes before she lost it she
actually said mercy first you know I'm
gonna be different but mercy for future
generations mercy for the kids of kids
who don't remember me new kina City
basically she's like Ultron in the sense
where it's like you have to burn
everything to the ground to start to
start averred or Thanos there's a lot of
MCU villains who have that kind of
attitude but uh let's move on to a
question look at this why is it furry
it's just like it's covered a bird at
Serafina 3:51 asks where did those wild
fire blasts come from so this is
interesting a lot of you guys got this
there were little green plumes a fire
that blasted when when drogon was
torching the city and there was like the
wild fire was mixing with dragon fire
wild fire of course we don't remember is
the explosive chemical that helped the
Lannisters defeat Stannis and his fleet
in battle Blackwater Bay and it helps
Cersei blow up the great Sept of Baelor
at the end of season six and some people
speculated that Cersei might have
actually planted all the wildfire either
as a trap for Daenerys and her army like
land mines so that like when they were
attacking the city she could just make
it look a lot worse than it was and
blame that look how evil these people
are so even if Daenerys didn't intend to
use dragon fire Cersei could have like
tried to lie and say like oh the reason
your home burned down is because though
that wasn't green that you saw it was
orange it was a while
from a dragon but this is just a way if
you could point to like more fire on the
stage look what your new queen did
totally the Mad King Aerys Targaryen is
leftover stores and caps to have little
I think who was it that actually wanted
to utilize the mad Kings love for fire
like he was the one who created and
generated what wildfire was and so when
he was ruling my belief is that he had
secret stores and pockets because he was
absolutely nuts
and so when Daenerys is blowing up
everything and you see the Mad King
stash coming up as well you're realizing
that the circle has become complete she
has completely turned into her father
and she's finishing the work that her
father started yep her father wanted to
get all the oil from Iraq and then her
the child completes the the journey
right daddy issues or her a real [ __ ]
yeah but let's move on to another
question okay at Maxwell knives is
asking what's the deal with the horse at
the I have to start off by saying when I
saw this moment it was like our tax was
coming to our tree anyway so this whole
white horse comes through even though
there's been absolute mess and
destruction everything's happening this
pure white horse comes to aya
basically she Woo's it and jumps on and
runs out of the city some people thought
that maybe bran walked into the horse to
help save his sister maybe the horse was
joking Hagar wearing the face of a horse
I think that's a strange horse
impression is a stretch may be confirmed
right yeah there's a white horses in
general just have a lot of symbolic
meaning you know there's the poor
Horsemen of the Apocalypse in the book
of Revelation we were saying oh I saw a
pale horse and it's rider was death and
they brought hell with him
but pale horse is technically yellow you
know if you do the the translation so
there's a white horse which represents
conquest or victory of the four horsemen
there's but the horse is also covered in
blood so is that like the red horse of
the four horsemen and the red horse
represents war an empire division point
but Daenerys also had that white horse
that was a wedding gift from Khal Drogo
died in season two and then
Ned Stark also rode a white horse white
horse covered in blood symbolizes hope
it's been damaged by violence like Aria
and all of Westeros had yeah so it's
kind of look at this a couple different
ways yeah and let's also talk about how
I interacted with the horse she
approaches it with tenderness she pets
it softly yes she's bonding which is the
thing that people do with horses Worsham
yeah and then I love you forever
she's like cool I'm gonna use you as
transport but it's the beautiful
juxtaposition we've had here is that you
know this city's collapsing there's huge
destruction rubbles flying everywhere
she's covered in blood and she's covered
in grime and then she's having this
beautiful soft quiet moment through all
this chaos so that's kind of its kind of
a grace note in the episode on that's
been so loud and over the top when the
spectacle is a quiet little moment it
was kind of a nice way to go out on well
we have a few video questions from
Stardust this is a social media app
where film and TV lovers share their
reactions through videos or text this
season we were holding a contest with
Stardust for two fans that tagged
Westeros weekly with a question about
Game of Thrones to get flown out to join
us to watch the finale in a special LIVE
Westeros weekly with us we announce one
winner last week we're gonna announce
our second winner this week after we
watch these selected questions first off
what an amazing episode secondly to all
the fans talking trash on this episode
you haven't been paying attention very
much to the show and thirdly we know
Daenerys is going to get offed what do
you think the unsullied and the Dothraki
and all her other followers are gonna do
after she is whether it's Arya or John
that does it yeah what's up new
rockstars you the best Westeros weekly
what's up so my question is what happens
to drag on if we kill Danny does drag on
stay with John because John's a
Targaryen you don't adopt a puppy from
the pound if that puppy just blew up an
entire city
I just don't think John's gonna want to
keep him and I don't think we really
need dragons anymore look what just
happened holy and John dude seriously do
not scream in this dragon you will die
[Laughter]
yes good points now that second clip was
from user Nevin champloo who is the
second winner for a big finale contest
thank you to everyone who submitted and
remember that you can still get tickets
to the finale screening and our live
Westeros weekly but just to kind of dig
into this question here because both are
these users brought up some really good
points about what will happen now there
was that moment with grey worm and John
where grey worm decided just to you know
asteroid moment where you had to have
patience but because he lost someone
that he loved he just because he takes
out the Lannister captain and then but
really great worms kind of eyeing John
where he's like you're telling people to
hold back you're kind of holding back
the charge right now it's it almost
seemed to be laying the seeds of
conflict between the two of them grey
worm doesn't answer to John he answers
to Danny Dan he's losing it and so easy
yeah so say we're in a situation where
Daenerys is taken out or they try to
take her out that's an assumption made
by both of them which I thought was
interesting yeah and I think a lot of us
are assuming that but what happens to
all the unsullied in the teaser for next
episode which you're gonna look at in a
couple minutes there's still thousands
of unsullied soldiers there's still some
Dothraki soldiers and there's still a
dragon yeah like how can you take those
out is there a force large enough that
John's faction could command to confront
them and what are other ways they could
kill a dragon at this point well I mean
Dragons already buggered off for a
little bit as well when he was not happy
with how things played out he got nearly
I would like to say abused throughout
that whole thing she used him to death
literally right yeah I was like really
still he's breathing fast know what
there's some like nerdy explanations of
how dragons could breathe fire that if
they had some kind of
inflammable gas that they would breathe
out because there are some insects that
will spit out like fluid and if their
teeth are made of like flint and steel
or something so it creates a spark blow
it out like a flamethrower whatever that
blew it most it it's magic it's magic I
won't talk about the unsullied though
because when you look at what's happened
with them they were trained slaves and
then she freed them so they are all free
men just like the northerners
but these freemen have seen what she has
done to other free people and she's
obliterated them all and then they kind
of like had a hand in that when some of
them maybe be like whoa you were
supposed to save the people and you've
just killed the people now that I'm free
I get to make my choice whether I
support you or not but then you see the
northerners who were free and they
followed John to the ends of the world
and then as soon as I go a little bit of
taste of chaos they're starting and
pillaging and raping you know this is
something that like has been brought up
in the books and on the show there's a
quote from sir Jorah and the show is sir
Barristan in the books about what
happens to men when you put a sword in
their hand or when they get a splash of
blood on them the beasts comes out
there's a beast inside all men's it's
kind of George RR Martin's commentary on
boar in general and how war is can
there's no like winners and losers
there's only losers in war so I kind of
like this episode in that it reminded us
of we shouldn't like be cheering on
bloodshed and they put us in the
perspective of the victims and they
deliberately confused us
there's start of a Lannister soldier
being basically like a first responder
doing the good guy thing and then cut
over to the stark men who were raping
people and in that scene that I mention
was surge or and Barristan surge or was
making the argument that because the
unsullied have been castrated that they
aren't like normal men they aren't going
to rape and pillage because they aren't
interested in raping so we don't know
how the unsullied went there we do know
that they were super violent and they
massacred women and children and it
wasn't cool but maybe less so than
John's people who one of whom he had to
kill yeah keep him from raping someone
that's a nasty so I guess my thing is
it's like does she have full control of
her armies still after what she's done
and is drugged I'm just gonna be like oh
that's me done Thanks yeah in terms of
like what could kill a dragon there was
kind of a theory that maybe would from a
weirwood tree might have some kind of
magical significance if he could fashion
like an arrow or a spear they'd shoot a
guy that was made by Gendry yeah yeah
something like that maybe ginjury could
be hard to work at something there was
like a theory when when Aegon the
conquerer forced torrents start to be
the king who knelt there was a last K in
the north before the modern era the
there was like a theory that one of his
relatives when the other Starks wanted
to come up with some secret plan to take
down balerion the dread and one of those
theories that he was using the wood from
a weirwood tree to do that so may
there's some kind of tactic there that
could be used it seems like something
that's in the mythology the books that
probably won't come into the show you
heard about the theory as well that when
drug on did disappear for half the
season it was to actually lay eggs right
and Valyria maybe yeah yeah mama Drogo
dragon is gonna go back to you know
raise her new steeds I hope not I want
the Dragons to end like it seems like
they served their purpose I kind of like
the point of one of our Stardust people
here just saying like we don't need
dragons anymore arguably did any dragons
in this battle it kind of gave a unfair
advantage and I'm and I'm kind of done
with dragons on the show now comes the
time for our Power Rankings it's the
part of the show where you guys decide
who you thought won the episode we sent
out Twitter poll last night you guys
voted at third place with a pretty
distant 4.5 percent of who they believe
is the most powerful this episode Varys
the spider the master of whispers
perhaps in his death the fact that he
was able to send out all these notes
that subverted Daenerys his power around
the continent was a pretty power move
for me I think the reason why is only
4.5% is this is the guy who has played
the game of Thrones probably the best
and he's never actually been loyal to a
person but he's been loyal to the
kingdom and he just didn't read John
enough to know that he's a muppet in
this situation and that he would have
you know he goes by his word too hard
and Varys saw what happened to Ned he
should have applied that yeah I'm I
could argue he knew that was gonna
happen and maybe that's like he knew
he's like you know what I'm going to die
with the last like effort I can yeah cuz
at this point I've already had enough
treasonous conversation he sold that
Tyrion was gonna betray him see I don't
know he seemed a bit surprised by that
but at least at peace with it you know I
believe that whatever he heard in the
flames does tie in to what his end was
but its second place with a sizable
chunk is 29 29.2% sander the Hound
Clegane yeah I think it's a big win for
him I believe the the confrontation
between him and his brother was the one
like battle this episode that totally
paid off clicking bow was really well
done this episode and he's finally at
peace now you know he went out exactly
how he wanted to he just wanted to make
sure that this man no longer was alive
and I thought I had to cost his life and
here I was a prize he was willing to pay
absolutely but
obviously number one forty five point
six percent of the vote decided that
daenerys targaryen won the episode yeah
there's really no argument here whether
or not you'd like this turn from her she
is definitely the most powerful
character on the show I feel like the
killcount aside for maybe like hardhome
and all of those like she has basically
killed the most people or the entire
season combined in one battle yeah it's
Joe Gunn so yes she's frightening at
this stage and I think yeah I think that
what's happened is whether it was done
well or not but the writers have
definitely made sure that with a flick
of the switch she is now the antagonist
that we thought you know it was the
night king initially and then we thought
was Cersei it's actually her being the
threat I just want to hijack this real
quickly I did a poll on my Twitter at
Maude Garrett and Ozzy asking who do you
think you would bend the knee to coming
into the finale fifty-one percent said
Jon Snow being the rightful heir and the
guy who's probably the most sane with
all of that and then at 32 percent I
believe it was Sansa only eight percent
said Danny like no one likes so now if
this is the popularity contest she's not
won well whether or not people like her
I just I think a lot of people had take
issue with what they've done with her
and they don't want this behavior to be
rewarded at the show but I could totally
see that happening if the show runners
decide that this is the statement they
want to make about the state of affairs
and Westeros maybe it is just like a
toxic toxic place it should be a
cautionary tale for our own political
situation we we shouldn't identify a
route for anything scared they do say
that history constantly repeats itself
and I feel like with this she was just
making such a name to not be like her
father to not be like every other ruler
to not use cruelty to not use chaos
death destruction blood and here she is
doing exactly that and that's what gets
her the reward yeah you're right yeah I
think she feels that that is her only
move left whether or not it is her only
move left I think she looked around the
room in Winterfell and realized she
doesn't have a family here she's never
going to win over these people with love
so in her mind fear and love are the
only ways you can appeal to people
despite there being plenty of ways to
appeal to people like having a good tax
plan or providing health care or maybe a
new system of government in which
leaders are elected by votes but
whatever it's the medieval times
there's no rules that medieval times you
can't use silverware there's only one
episode left folks let's watch a teaser
for next week's finale and give our
quick reactions to the already Martha
Lister yeah
[Music]
[Music]
well winter is back seems like winter
has found its way down to King's Landing
finally or is it yeah so much ash that
it looks like snow well we see there
that cherien's surfaced so he's safe and
sound no possibly has repercussions to
pay it looks so doom and gloom and she
looks like that all of the goodness from
her is just completely disintegrated and
that she's just she went to the dark
side man yeah well what do we want to
see in this finality there's still other
characters out an active Brienne Sansa
Brianna bran it was bran run still got
the crossbow he wants Highgarden he's
gonna come back for it I also saw that
someone tweeted how good would it have
been if you actually cut to Winterfell
and there's brand who's actually
witnessing this entire thing unfold and
he was just like yeah this is basically
what I what I first saw or maybe he was
just like oh dear
you know is the final episode gonna
Twilight Zone breaking down part to us
and it's all brands vision everything we
saw it did not actually happen oh my god
as whatever I didn't like about this
season if they retcon it that way it's
all bets are off my my beef I guess is
that this is supposed to be a song of
Fire and Ice now it's become a song of
fire versus ice yes rather than song of
ice yet together yeah yeah yeah I do
hope that the bad behavior is punished
at the end of the show I there's part of
my the troll inside me just wants to see
it all burn and all these characters die
at each other's hands but I you know the
final book is supposed to be a dream of
spring I don't know if that's what the
next episode title is gonna be a dream
of spring but if so I would hope that
there is some kind of like a sign of
hope at the end of this some kind of and
I think ending with Arya leaving death
yeah rather than turning backward at
where Danny might be that might be
enough of a sign of hope for me to say
that this series might end in a way that
feels good yeah but do you think they're
the three Starks vs. Danny a dragon the
unsullied and the Dothraki is enough
no I don't I don't it's uh but maybe
slow dripping poison by Martha of the
Dragonstone kitchen yeah might be enough
well uh I want to get in your bed here
what is who's your final page why you
Danny who do you think is gonna end up
on the phone I mean I think that's a
really great point you have but Danny is
clouded I really do think that her turn
to the dark side means that she's having
a Circe moment where she cannot see
actual threat anymore she feels like
she's indestructible we saw what
happened to Circe it didn't work and I
think that's what's gonna happen with
her all of this power doesn't mean that
you're smart with it and I think that
when you've got iyer who can steal faces
you've got Sansa who's becoming more
clever than Tyrion and then you've got
John who has the backing of his people
and can use love my guess is John's
going to I don't know if he's
manipulating I'm manipulative enough to
do it but coerce Danny into a false
sense of security and then in her life
yeah I could see that happening I hope
that neither of them get to the Iron
Throne as much as I like John I I think
he's been too noble he's been to Ned
Stark in his play of it I want there to
be a new system if Daenerys did indeed
break the wheel here I want there to be
some kind of new power system that
elects leader is there even an Iron
Throne anymore did we see it there yeah
we saw the Lannister such a window get
blast through but we didn't see inside
the red you kind of wish the drug on
melted that's right that would've been
nice yeah didn't break the wheel she
broke this that might happen it so
happened well let us know what your
predictions are for this final episode
we have some more thoughts coming out
this week on it that's enough for this
episode of Westeros weekly thank you for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to the Westeros weekly podcast and
follow our new MCU podcast speed inside
Marvel for all of our in-game Avengers
spider-man stuff follow us on Twitter at
new rock stars tweet us your Game of
Thrones questions from using the hashtag
Westeros weekly you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter a TA boss I'm on
at Mont garret and over at geek balm
I've been doing break downs the smaller
variety the little snackable bite-size
where you get such beautiful things like
the art x and i Atreyu comments and the
fact that jaime and cersei smell what
The Rock was cooking and got Barney
Rubble so if you want to check out those
make sure you subscribe every geek balm
we're nearly at a hundred thousand times
well thank you for joining us this week
mod the mod Queen
maude Queen runs the knee bless your
having you and the pleasure having all
of you guys we got some great videos and
podcasts playing for this week's to stay
tuned thanks have a good week one more
episode to go one more it's hard to
believe
[Music]